[Applause]
first of all speaking of
sharing uh life together
i got this package at work today i think
you might have heard what a
stalker fan of marie kondo i am
a stan apparently is what it's called
well apparently someone in the marie
condo world maybe watches the show
because
it worked i got sent a box today
and i feel a thrill i can't even tell
you in fact it says
right here in the box from marie kondo
herself it's a quote
from the great almighty marie condo
when something sparks joy you should
feel a little thrill as if the cells in
your body are slowly rising
yeah she's so wise
yeah it's exciting you know what
i feel like i may just be
one step closer to marie kondo
closer to condo hashtag closer to condo
i'm gonna save this until after the show
it'll be like a treat i'm looking
forward to
and you know also maybe they don't think
i'm so crazy and won't arrest me and
give me a restraining order that's
exciting
i have hope all right we have some great
news
for fans of saturday night live i was
just talking about this with the vffs
i am a super fan snl season 46 premieres
tomorrow night oh my gosh it's tomorrow
night already
chris rock and musical guest
megan the stallion
i mean i hosted the show for the first
time when i was seven years old still
the youngest host i'm proud to say
yeah that was in 1982. julia louise
dreyfus
and eddie murphy was on the cast brad
hall who ended up marrying julie louise
dreyfuss joe piscopo tim kraszowinski
i could go on robin duke um anyway with
an uh in an interview with the new york
times of course it was with the new york
times
lauren michael said they're back in
studio 8h
but totally rethinking how they make the
show
and here's what their brand new table
read looks like by the way this is like
hot off the press this photo hasn't even
gone around really yet
um and it's a big election year as we
all know with wow
three more debates this month
i'm sure they won't get any good
material there so
um the show's gonna do something that
it's never done before
it's doing five live weeks in a row with
no breaks
and um you know so they just want to
like digest and give us what's happening
in news and pop culture
and i'm just so glad that they're back
and making it work
because it's nice to be able to have
intelligent
comedy writing about our world satirical
news for me
has been a great coping mechanism in my
life
and i just really have sort of
the most deepest respect for
saturday night live it is an institution
you know what i mean
so i'm i need it i can't wait for
tomorrow night
i'll watch it with my friends on dvr
probably the next day because i don't
think i've stayed up till 11 30 in a
really long time
okay next up if you love beefy bears
guess what it's officially
i'm not kidding this is what it's called
fat bear week
yeah it's a real thing so
officials at cat mine national park in
alaska host the annual competition to
pick the year's
bulkiest brown bears check out these
contenders including
walker otis and chunk by the way
totally goonies here is the last winner
uh last year's winner holly this is her
compared
in september when she took the title and
and yeah it's a before and after
hashtag fat bear week i'm in i like it
i love a good little fat bear
[Music]
chuck
you